when i was really young i was scared to  death of thunder and lightning  and then that fear turned into intense  passion and i've been storm chasing ever  since  all right let's go our goal is to  understand why these storms are becoming  more intense  hopefully we can take that information  and save more lives down the road  this is tornado alley high planes  insanity about to happen  wow look at that we're gonna get the  bird they are at this next overlook big  time structure on this deal  holy cow tornado warning  mega shot cloud on this thing that is  amazing  oh that's big big time we are getting  hammered  wow now  here comes kicking up dirt kicking up  dirt clothes  oh my god this is what it looks like  when you're looking straight up and a  funnel has to send me down  you